[Music]
hello everybody uh i've said that i have
to put this slide up there
to cover everybody involved uh in brief
it says that
i shouldn't you know whatever i say may
not be actually what beckman culture
deems to be
part of their product announcements and
so as you can see here
there's just some legal jargon um
because we tend to like
to change things a little bit when we
use our instruments so this is their way
of saying that it's
what i did not them
okay so this is the srt
uh we were going to show the live one
but i can walk through this here
so it's a if you've seen a cytoflex s
it's slightly bigger it's about the same
size as the lx
and it has
actual the ability to hold 15 ml tubes 5
ml tubes
i would say if you if it fits you can
sort into it
um if you can actually see the back side
here uh behind the tubes the tube's kind
of blocking it but that's a
plate holder so you can sort into plates
obviously within that there's a groove
for slides
uh you can see the sample injection
chamber this is very similar to a mofo
astrios in the sense that
a
plastic tubing comes down over and
pressurizes the tube in the chamber
at the moment
the holder will only take 5 ml tubes or
we have used it for epinedos
so that's a possibility
and inside the black piece there with
the uh
thunderbolt we'll call it the electrical
thing that this is where you actually
have
uh the cameras
your plates and your
nozzle
we will show the nozzle also
at some point it's just a little picture
uh apologies again for not being able to
show that live but and you can see
there's a door that shuts closed so that
there is a level of protection there for
the the operator
uh and you can actually if you can kind
of see on this on the
total uh let's see right hand side
there is a you know you can start to see
the opening there this is where you put
one of those uh you know buffalo
uh airbag systems
so it does come with a an actual filter
system that you can use
uh to
just a higher level of assurance that
you know the operator is safe
and in these days most of us are wearing
masks and
full gear anyways
so it's an extra level of protection for
ourselves
now we'll talk about the features a
little bit some things that i actually
kind of like about this
and work with and
can
i guess makes me happy compared to a lot
of other things that i've used
um it has the same optical footprint as
a cytoflex s so
this is one of those instances uh and
companies are doing this more and more
where they actually have complementary
platforms
so that things that you do for analysis
that you may
do a quick pilot type experiment or you
find something that may be interesting
that you didn't see before you can
actually take that
exact
uh you know template and data and move
it right over to the sorting instrument
uh the other thing is most of the stuff
that's on this is wizard-based so it's
it's pretty easy to set up there's not
there's not a lot of thought that needs
to be taken place and a lot of these
things can even be done remotely
such as through something like a zoom
anything that would kind of give you
control to the software would allow you
to do
most of the setup and getting the
instrument ready to sort
from even a remote location
so if you need to get your morning
coffee
uh you can be doing it right from your
your local cafe or you know even home so
maybe the beach
here in boston it's not really beach
weather but
maybe from where you are you can do that
all year long so there's also this call
for gentle with their i italicized it
because gentle sorting meaning you know
we're not going to activate cells we're
not going to shrek them or you know
fragment them cause
cellular death
so using a larger
orifice on the on the nozzle tip
along with a lower pressure now most of
the time 100 micron
tip is operated around 30 20 to 30 psi
on this instrument they've even gone a
little bit lower you still get a very
efficient break off and satellite drops
but at 15 psi you're getting a lot less
force or turbulence going through the
nozzle tip
we also uh as most sorters do have index
sorting and here they also put into that
uh rare event visualization and we'll
we'll show that
hopefully it makes sense when we
actually show the representation there
and finally something near and dear to
my heart the same thing that has on the
cytoplex s is this violet side scatter
this enables us to look at things that
are
smaller than we're normally
used to looking at so if your normal
cellular size is from three to
fifteen microns we're talking about
things that would actually be in the 100
to 500 nanometer range
so a lot smaller
than your average lymphocyte even a red
blood cell platelet
so we'll see that
give you some ideas of what we can do
application so this is what we were just
talking about so we have all those
wonderful features but who cares if we
can't do anything with them
so here we're going to have a lot of
diverse samples of they stated we're in
a core
so
we operate for everyone it's not just
departmental so we're doing lots of
different things like stem cell biology
uh immune responses
neuroscience hematology vaccine research
so uh you know humac type
things we have a humanized mouse model
that we've been working on lately
and obviously this extracellular vesicle
microrna research which goes into even
like lipid nanoparticles and
uh virus-like particles things that
along with this immune response are very
prevalent in the age of covid
looking at
the different aspects of vaccinations
and
the response that takes place maybe you
know
behold cytokine arrays
so let's break down each of these
features uh first and foremost so like
we said it is the same optical footprint
as a cytoflex s
so what does that mean
well if you crack open the top which you
actually can do that's uh it's actually
not frowned upon um my level of taking
things apart is frowned upon but
this is things they don't mind you
seeing right if you open the cover and
you can see that the srt is very similar
and to the s you have the exact same
filter sets
uh you know you have the exact exact
same laser format they usually come in a
four laser format
here you can see there's a four for the
srt the setup like s has a three
which just happened to be the picture i
had
mine has four
and this is basically
violet blue yellow green and red
and each of those has filter sets which
are interchangeable as you can see the
hand there in the upper right hand
corner
everything can come out you can arrange
them in any way you want um basically
we'll show why in a second for those
that do not know
but these are basically plug and play
any uh fluorophore that you can think of
as long as you have that particular
excitation wavelength you can
place any filter in there to capture
that light
on the emission
so again
absolutely the exact same structure from
a optics standpoint
so this really lends itself to
to some wonderful discovery and then the
ability to sort
a particular population of interest out
so here's what we were talking about
this is a kind of
cartoonish type
representation of what's going on
um they are very much smaller than
what's represented here on the picture
but
those are your filter sets um and
basically what's going to happen is
there's a bar there that this is an
actual mirror so you have
on the bottom right your fiber optic
cable bringing in the laser light
the laser light is then going to be
focused
into the first uh spot which the light
will start to bounce off of
and it'll collect in all of those you
can see the apd's in the back so what is
that how does it do it
well here it is it's the same setup we
have the laser light coming in showing
you so i wasn't lying we have a fiber
optic cable that sends the light in
and then we have the light bouncing back
and forth if you happen to be that
particular uh
wavelength of light going through you
will go into the apd you'll pass through
if you are not you bounce you hit the
mirror and you try the next one when it
gets to the end it just doesn't fade
away or
that's it it keeps bouncing back and
forth in this pattern
and maximizing efficiency and maximizing
signal
so and the apd's are able to amplify
that signal and be very efficient due to
the fact that they are also cooled this
is done through a
piezoelectric type function uh and by
cooling the apd's you get a broader band
of
signal that you can get and the
signal-to-noise ratio
increases by decreasing the dark noise
in the back and allowing for greater
signal this is going to be very
important when we get to the end and
talk about our extracellular vesicle
sorting or detection
so keep that in the back your mind
please
here we're just going to go with some
more of the ease of use and that
complementary type information so again
actually within this srt software
because the site expert software for the
two are slightly different
you have the ability to convert an
experiment
so if you have that site expert
experiment from a cytoflex s
you can take that information put it on
a usb drive plug it into your srt and
tell it to convert the experiment to a
sorting experiment
and there it will just say on the
convert it will ask you to find the
experiment and give it a new name
and you can see here that that
information can be taken this is just an
example that we have of
something that was done
on a cytoflex and then converted over to
the srt
to do some single uh
cell sorting
so again
just ease of use this is just another
function that makes it easy and makes it
complementary so you're really able to
start
planning things a little bit better
not to mention that most institutions
could mine included will charge you more
for sorting than they will for use of uh
analysis
so
doing a bunch of pilot experiments to
find out you don't you know you don't
have anything reasonable on a sorter is
not only more time consuming but more
costly and so it just opens up the
opportunities a lot more
people were designing experiments for
the sorters because it was
well if we're going to sort we need to
be able to have the settings there we
can't just transfer them this has taken
care of that problem and obviously made
life
better and easier in this aspect
another feature is that we have all
these to make it
this ease of use and keep hammering that
one home
is there's a wizard-based setup so
everything like i said it can be done
remotely you don't have to be there but
it's really making it simple you don't
really have to think about much you just
got to be able to click some buttons
so if you can't be there you can walk
someone very easily through the setup uh
so that they can
you know be sorting in no time at all
so let's go through that process
here you can see
the top is listing which parts of this
are automated and which parts are
actually menu so overall it's called a
semi automated
sorting
or you know as it says up there the
intelligent sorting power
so there you have some sort regions and
things that you can set once you get to
the setup and the sort part but
everything before that
is very simplistic in all this
wizard-based
total from turning the machine on to
being able to and ready to sort
is
maximum 30 minutes uh sometimes this can
be even
even faster you may you know the machine
may save some time here or there
so
while the videos are in hyper speed i'll
try to talk you through them uh to make
a little more sense so here
the wizard tells you okay put in your
nozzle tip
now the nozzle tip does look like this
we'll get a little better picture of it
shortly
and it's basically looking like a
a one of the new keys for a car or
something like that it's it's
rather large the opening
is smaller um but
hard to lose this uh this key it's large
enough that it's not you know it's not
like the the little tiny ceramic ones
where if you drop it you have no idea
where it went um
and it's expensive to get a new one uh
so these are are pretty large and hefty
hard to break and the o-rings that are
on them that seal them do come off
they're not fused on so if you lose one
you can obvious just replace it it has a
deep enough groove that they stay in
pretty fit
the only opposite to that is you're
going to have to
uh you know make sure that that stays
firm in there so i like to uh you know
take the end of
whether it's a
cotton tip applicator or something and
just kind of make sure that it is in its
groove and
stays nice this will also give you a
good seal
once you put it into the actual sorting
unit so that you don't have any leaks so
let's start that let's get the starter
film
here you can see
the sheet tanks pressurize you do a
fluidic self diagnosis this is basically
saying there's no air leaks
no problems it goes through a d bubble
also which means that it's debugging the
the sheet um
filter
and the uh
sort chamber there
in the nozzle so in the nozzle it's
doing a and also a d bubble
and then it's basically saying okay you
are all set to go we don't have any
leaks we don't have any problems
and everything is warm and ready to run
then it's going to give you this message
do you want to go straight to qc
well normally the answer to this is yes
and so we are going to go to straight to
qc
qc
has its own set of beads these beads
have a
number lot numbers which are associated
to their actual values
so by just importing that in it's going
to put all the qc values this is just
normal qc stuff if you've done
anything on a flow cytometer you realize
okay this is a basic qc but it's all
automated so again unless there's a
problem you don't have to do much
thinking on it except for do i have the
right lot number on my bottle to
coincide to the right lot number that is
in the system
and so basically you put those in you
hit the run button
and it starts to go so it says it
configures the system which is just it's
saying yes it's on and it's ready to go
it starts to look at
very fast here it starts to look at the
cvs it looks at the voltages
and it gives the numbers and according
to what its set numbers are it's going
to tell you if it passes or fails
uh basically if it fails
nine times out of ten it's a fluidics
issue such as an air bubble
and it does give you within the software
the ability to go up into
uh the cytometer
uh drop down menu and tell it to
do another
round
of de-bubbling in the sheath filter and
in the nozzle
so you can do that you can do back
flushes to get rid of that and then just
re-run the qc and it usually passes
there's not much of an issue there laser
delays are also accomplished during this
time once that goes through and you get
the qc report you get the thumbs up um
oh final thing that it will actually do
is calculate your drop delay one so this
is giving you that kind of distance on
the drop so that you are ready and set
to go with some calibration of the
droplet now so it's identified the first
droplet and the break off and now it's
going to allow you to actually
set that
droplet and maintain the system so
that's where we're going in the little
box i'm not sure how easy it is to see
but it's saying it past qc and do you
want to go on to start calibration
so again very much a wizard one thing to
the next to the next not much thought
process there unless there is an issue
which we know
in the world of flow cytometry issues
are not that uncommon um
and most of them are very easy to to
repair
uh in this type fashion
if you get to the qc it's usually like i
said just an air bubble or some sort of
blockage in the fluidic system
so let's go ahead and do start to sort
calibration which is going to allow us
to calibrate the droplet calibrate our
side streams so the four side streams
will be calibrated on a phase the
voltage for them to separate them this
is all automated and the actual
distance into the
tubes or plates or anything else is all
initially calibrated
so this is just going and confirming
that calibration
yes you have the ability to move things
if this gets off for some reason but
again if it is off it is most likely a
problem in the fluidics or the nozzle
tip so instead of going and moving
everything around you're going to want
to make sure your nozzle tip is clean
you're going to want to make sure you
don't have any air bubbles that may be
causing this because if you go and you
fix the problem and
by changing
positionings
and then you clear your air bubble you
clear your partial clock then you're
going to run into the same problems over
and over and you're going to have to fix
it again
so make sure before going into something
like that that you've done due diligence
so let's run this one too
so you can see it's going very fast it's
determining that calibration where the
drop the split is the six droplets it is
looking to see if those little micro
uh
spheres there our wreath are set and
actually
uh inserting themselves back into the to
the larger droplets so the micros are
going into the actual
larger droplets and it's looking for
that
and the break off it's then determining
the drop delay and it's going to set the
drop delay now the
other thing that has now happened with
this this process is even
quicker and smoother
when you get a nozzle tip
what it will have on its packaging
is the suggested value so each one of
these have been calibrated uh in
house before you get them
uh and basically it will read
information on what your frequency and
amplitude should be
and you can set those you can see on the
bottom here there's something that says
manual droplet calibration
if you click that it's going to give you
a box which allows you to type in that
frequency and amplitude this will give
it a starting point
and also
make it even quicker and easier
alright so we have a comment that is
impossible to see something in the
pictures
i apologize for this i was gonna run
through some of it but it seems as
though we're not able to get
um actual video
i may time allowing be able to go into
the software itself to show these
um
but we'll see how that goes we might be
able to do that at the end
if i keep talking fast enough
during the extra time we have for
questions so
i apologize again bear with me hopefully
i can get that to you
um if it's a specific picture we can try
to go back
um it's with these little videos i've
tried to blow them up um but it gets
very distorted
okay so the last one's just shut down
and that's nothing special it's just
going to take to ask you to take the
nozzle tip out
it's going to run through a cleaning
of itself
and then basically
tell you to manually wipe down your
plates
uh your cameras you know to make sure
there's no built up salt or anything you
know obviously the sheath fluid is pbs
um when exposed to air it forms crystals
crystals when left too long will
actually start to eat away at you know
camera
and optics coverings and stuff like that
and distort images which will cause
problems
so
it
again another wizard it tells you
everything that you need to do
again if there's a particular picture
that's not coming through that you
really want to see um hit it up on there
on the chat because i am trying to pay
attention to that and i can see what i
may be able to do to make it a little
clearer for you
all right the other thing you're going
to see um
is this when you start to sort so in
those manual
functions there it says sort setup and
sort
so in the sort setup
and the sorting this is the actual uh
total sort setup and kind of logic
operator that you have
so you have the four different
uh sort
paths
so left one left two right one right two
you can put any of them you can use all
four
usually the logics
for sorting go from uh outer left to
outer right to the inner left to the
inner right
and this is based on the rarity of the
population this is just a this has been
kind of the thought process in sorting
for as long as i can remember
um
i haven't found that it is necessarily
the exact same here i've sorted rare
populations into each of them getting
pretty much the same efficiencies in
recovery
but
you know rules of thumbs are there for a
reason so
you can choose all the sort modes here
you can give target counts of what you
would like
um you can tell it which tube size
you're using so 5 ml or 15 ml and give
it the initial volume the initial volume
is set there so that it no it calculates
basically and it knows well if you have
an ml in there and it's a 5ml tube i can
only sort enough volume for 4 ml
without overflowing it doesn't want it
to overflow
so not even four would come down to like
a 3.9 because it doesn't want to even
get to the very top
and cause any kind of loss of materials
you can also see that the stop criteria
can be set to a number of events that
you process or number or a time that you
want to sort by
and it gives you all the abort counts
rates
the actual sort counts and rates and
your efficiency which is just basically
your aborts
your sort count divided by your reports
and it gives you the percentage and then
also the percentage volume that is
accumulated within
the actual sample
and all this will be kept within a sort
report
so you have all this information and
freedom to put in um i like the fact
that i'm not gonna overflow the tubes
and i say that because i accidentally
did it on my aria just last week
because i was preparing this slideshow
and wasn't paying attention
to the uh
to the store that was going extremely
fast on one of the populations and uh
luckily he only needed a certain amount
of sample not all of it because i would
have really felt bad oh even if he just
said that i guess he was trying to make
me feel better
so
this is a very useful tool for those of
us who don't like to pay attention all
the time
this is the now gentle sorting you can't
see me but i'm putting up air quotes
and this is here a picture of the nozzle
it's a hundred micron like we said
there's the 15 psi
you can see what i was talking about
with the uh the o-ring or the ball seal
that is there on the nozzle that seals
it into the system when you put the
nozzle tip in and like i said this is
not fixed down so you can actually
remove it replace it because they will
get worn
um if you look at it and it looks more
like a
red blood cell than it does a a perfect
donut then you're going to want to
replace that
it even gives you an arrow on which way
to put it in
and which side is up um
that's kind of
funny to me but i guess if you i i would
say if you need that assistance on which
way it should go in and which side is up
not sure i want you sorting
your own stuff at that point but hey
that's i guess that's time for another
talk um
but the other part of this is when you
see that serial number this is what i
was talking about this the serial
numbers are associated with certain
frequency and amplitude which can be
typed in
as part of a you know that initial sort
calibration
so what do we mean gentle sorting well
any of us who want to do 10x type
genomics
we're looking at
here is their recommendations for
sorting
so if you're going to do some sort of
genomics especially this 10x they say
well we want you to at least sort on
purity right opposed to any kind of
yield or enrich because they want really
pure samples which can be read so that
your data is maximized
it suggests also this larger nozzle size
oh look we just so happen to have a 100
micron nozzle on this instrument
and they want you to use as low as
pressure as possible when sorting your
cells
they're saying that this is going to
help preserve your cell health and its
viability obviously they're healthy
they're going to be alive
so
again in most circumstances they're
saying it's better to sort at a lower
flow rate so you make that still help
less pressure
increase nozzle size
and this will
allow for less uh
turbulence through the through the flow
cell and through the nozzle it's going
to allow the sorted cells to be
healthier happier and you're going to be
able to run these assays so the higher
that sorting efficiency the better that
outcome is going to be for reading
and being able to do genomics proteomics
things like that
um and i just found it very interesting
that this was on their their website as
what you should do while sorting and i
said well this fits perfectly with what
i want to talk about with gentle sorting
so what does all that actually lead to
so
here
is another thing
i know that most of the people i get
that come in and want to
need to do genomics
are very
strapped for time or they say i could
only get an appointment at this time i
could only do this i can only do that i
need to get through this okay so we
decided to take some
uh
car t cells that were labeled with gfp
that's the original up in the upper left
of what we have for a the gfp sample
we go and we're going to sort that at
different rates because not only do we
want them to be happy and healthy we
don't want them sitting around
they're going to get
less happy as they just keep sitting so
you don't want to be
sorting cells for hours upon hours again
it's also cost efficient not to be
sorting for hours and hours
so what we're doing here is taking the
look well if i sort a thousand events
per second if i sort at
4 000 events per second if i sort at 11
000 events per second
does that affect the cells
does it affect the fluorescence
intensity
does anything actually happen because if
i can sort faster and still get
very
good results in viable cells then this
is going to be the perfect situation
so here you can see those
on the actual post sorts you can see
that we're at basically 99 98 97 going
all the way to 11 000 events per second
i think once you get in the range of 11
000 15 000
you start to lose some of the linearity
um because it's just a processing thing
and i believe
it also depends on the rarity of the
cells these are okay in a starting
percentage of 26 but i would think if
you had something that was down 5 or
less
this could be more of an issue
but if you look at the events per second
comparison overlay
you get very good results again
obviously this is going to help us
understand what our optimal is so i
think sorting around four thousand five
thousand bets per second for this
particular cell
um the car t cells
it is going to be perfect um but
it's not necessarily terrible if you're
sorting at a faster rate so it's going
to be putting a little bit of hey
do we want
as many as possible at the highest
intensity
or do we want maybe a fewer
cells
but we're getting through it quickly
enough that we you know can get to our
next appointment and we can start doing
uh downstream analysis
because once again
if we have live cells we have happy
cells and happy cells give us better
results
all right another wonderful feature
index sorting and rare event
visualization so let's see what all that
means most of us are familiar with index
sorting so if you've done sorting into
96 well plates you understand what index
sorting is
here what this allows us to do is
actually see
where those events are coming from
so when we're just doing some actual uh
sorting
of cells whether into a plate uh
or into tubes on the rare event type
population um
if you get like that it's usually going
to be the 96 well plate that you can
sort into
and the holder as long as it's in
the same kind of size of a 96 well plate
it'll hold anything so if you actually
3d print a i don't know
let's say a 30
uh
point
you know plate you can do that you just
have to realign
you know the stream because you can do
custom
on it
uh so with these days i've seen it all
where people you know
3d printing all kinds of different
holders and
and whatnot we've done terasaki plates
in previously which are
the same size of 96 but a little tighter
on the format
we didn't 3d print anything we actually
just cut out
the plastic from a 96 well plate and
inserted the teresaki plate into it
but you know
you two i guess what you have at your
disposal and i don't have a 3d printer
so
all right so what happens here well we
have these rare events so we saw in the
last uh slide that we can
put on this index we can look back at it
and see where the particular cells from
a well came from
here we're looking at this very rarish
population at one percent
basically and to give it a little more
if we're going back here so that
population let's see
is over here
as you can see in the upper right that's
that population that's clustered with
all these blue
kind of dots that's that rare event type
portion
and simply by
taking that off you can see where these
guys lay
the reason doing that is simply the rare
event analysis as you can see it's a
little clearer and easier to see those
bunch of big squares than it is
for these possible uh little dots and
this was uh
a lot of little dots uh you know a lot
of total in order down the panel to get
to this many as a one percent to be able
to see that population so by making it
more visual you don't have to lose as
many cells in the sample and so you can
maximize your output
here we're looking at just simply cd4
versus cd8 and we're going to sort the
cd8s in this particular instance into
a 96 wall plate
and here i have my cells being sorted
into that 96 wall plate and you can see
the index sort will come up at the end
and what that's going to do is any place
that you pick
and i just pick the two corners just for
visual aspects
you can see
that the little blocks come up and they
show you exactly from the region of
where that cell of interest came from
now if you're doing different drug
treatments or something like that this
information may be very useful because
if you start noticing that a certain
drug treatment all clusters in a certain
area of disordered population you may be
able to make you know more educated uh
type
decisions on there or say you know oh
it's actually the you know the dim ones
or the bright ones or whatever the case
may be so you it just adds information
for you or if you're going through the
entire panel and you want to see where a
particular one started
you can just backtrack and see that that
particular put a gate around it and go
backwards and see where it originated
now this is going to be something that
we're going to go through this is uh
what we had done when we were doing some
uh
sorting previously
we did this for paper and cytometry a
using our
our astros platform along with a seligo
and we redid it on the srt just to
as a quality check so we basically are
sorting single gfps here
into a plate
we're trying to obviously fill the
entire plate
now obviously graphically
making this you can see where we may
have missed
uh to be a single cell or maybe this
could be an instance where we have two
or three that clustered in and got
sorted at the same time accidentally
but looking at these
via a microscope per se and you're
seeing here just you know one single dot
maybe honest you know you use the plate
you're looking under a microscope can
take a long time to go through each well
identify the spot because they're not
always going to sit directly in the
middle so you got to find them take a
picture of them
and see where you
landed
or you didn't
so what we did is use this illegal
instrument from nexalom
that is got a bright field and it's also
uh has used as fluorescence and it's
going to scan the entire plate this
process from setting it up to scanning
the plate takes approximately five
minutes
so
why is that good at all or you know
besides buying another instrument how is
this helpful
well for me
in doing this study we looked and it's
extremely helpful because what we did is
we took ourselves some uh
some jerk hot cells or some gila and the
gfp labeled
we took the gfp positives
we sorted them as you can see here on
the index sort that's done
and it gives us again more information
we can track back where they came from
if they're actually positive if there's
one or two
and by putting this into this illegal
we're not only getting what the index
sort is telling us happen
we're actually seeing the cell
live
and in person and what that's going to
do is benefit me in the sense of let's
say in my initial sort here
i'm about 80 efficient i believe it was
you know we looked at it say like 70 80
now what we do is we identify you can
see the red one here the red one was
where we put a
higher number of cells so that we could
identify the cell
show the siliga what we were looking for
and then ask for it to find the singles
and the rest of the 96 well plate
it's also going to give a number
excuse me
to
how many cells are in there so if you
have more than one it will tell you that
in this particular instance it gave us
it showed us that we either had one or
none at all
because it's so fast and only takes
about five minutes without the selfie
compromise or dying or any other issues
we can go back
and we can sort again and just tell the
instrument to sort in the wells that
didn't have anything
now we did that you can see we get up to
90 percent maybe even slightly more
um
on this instance and we can do the same
thing so now we spent about let's say
sorting a plate we set it up and
everything we're maybe no more than 30
minutes into this entire experiment
and we can actually fill out almost all
the plate
in this actual graphical representation
we we did our job we filled out the
whole thing but you can see in the
bottom left that we were a little more
uh
stringent there and reporting exactly
what happened and you can see that from
the instruments we went to about 78 79
up to 90
and then basically to 98
um
and 98 in this because we did fill all
the wells but there was uh
one
or two at times that got more than one
cell it was only two they were kind of
stuck together i guess
um
so it does happen but it gives it an
entire representation so if uh someone
comes back and asks about it and says
hey my stuff in a girl you say well it
was all there it was all in the wells uh
here's you know you were with me you saw
here's the you know the actual
representation
so
let's see what we can do different
all right
now we know why the machine may be
a good choice what benefits it brings to
to us
how it can
you know bring our science to the next
level and make it efficient and
dare i say faster right because we all
want results faster we all want results
to be
much better
because the faster we can get things
done the faster we can start publishing
and then we can get money right we're
all this is all it is
we're publishing so that we can get more
grants so we can publish some more so we
can get more grants
and we want to do this as quick as
possible
let's go into a couple of examples so uh
we you know my colleague brandi very
good at sorting she's been now with the
doing some stem cell biology and all the
things we talked about
and one of the groups that we're working
with uh has a very interesting uh study
that's associated around looking at
um cd150 to slam within the uh
regulatory t cells and how this is
involved in in bone marrow injury and
graftman
and they're working with another group
that's using the uh cd39 so
here you're looking at via the cd73 and
they're trying to talk about cellular uh
essence
um quiescence
so oxidative stress is going to cause
big problems it's actually going to
eliminate the t-rex and then the t-rex
cannot do their job in the when they're
doing this in graph so
we are taking the the stem cells that
are cd150 high we're sorting those out
so that they can then transplant these
back into the mouse model
and be able to see if there's a down
regulation of the cd73 and what the
involvement of cd 39 is so that you can
have more efficient treatment
of a tumor so that the the marrow is not
compromised that you may not have
these kind of
i call them almost stealth
you know tumor molecules or cancer cells
because as you wipe everything out even
in these car t scenarios and whatnot
there's always going to be these these
others that are kind of hidden in the
system hence you know it looks like
remission but then you can have a
reoccurrence or a lot of times it
manifests itself in a new type of cancer
so this is one study using
stem cell biology to try to
understand the system and understand the
you know the t-rex in this in this 150
high niche
and how the mechanism actually works
to down regulate ross
and be able to you know have survival of
the regulatory t cells
so again we started doing this on the
srt because it's gentler we're getting
better results we're getting clearer
pictures simply because apd's
as we said the signal to noise ratio
is better giving us a more enhanced
signal on even some of these that we
wouldn't necessarily expect psi 7 may
not be the best of the best
but
it's working perfectly we're able to get
great separation you can change the
filter so that we can use yfp instead of
gfp
and even though we do not have a uv
laser we're able to very
nicely see a separation between
dappy positives and negatives so that we
can make sure that we're sorting on live
cells
another one is this immune response and
viral resistance now
this is a huge hot topic obviously
everybody knows the reason
um but there's also many other things
that we've looked at and that are being
studied for over years and years and
years and knowing that even here the nih
is pouring lots of money into hiv
research
we've talked to companies that are doing
dengue research
zika virus
which is a another one of these things
that was
very well studied in the lab that is
right above me in the center for vaccine
research they did a lot of studies with
zika and are now have moved on to uh you
know sars kovet
too and also along with um
they look at a lot of hiv in its
variants
so this is something that it happened
that a colleague of ours who started
coming from a uh
an institution within our area
um they started sorting with us and
again you can see here i'm using those
blocks to actually see very well where
that population exists and making sure
that i am sorting the correct population
for this individual and this is looking
at the
non-structural protein one uh that is
part of this zika kind of uh
virus so this is also what we're doing
here is sorting into 96 well plates lots
of 96 volume plates
uh to clone the b cell so we can have uh
b cell clonality which will then be able
to be mixed with the zika and the ns1
and to see how that immune modulation
can take place uh the ns1 is shown in a
zika uptick in that zika's immune
response
really kicks high
so if we can figure out how to control
the ns1 well this particular group
um
in these anti-ns1 b-cell cultures then
it's really going to give some
information and hopefully have an effect
on zika and
how it affects those
uh in
in africa and populations where you know
these type diseases such as dengue as we
said hiv malaria
really have a stranglehold
so
another another instance where being
able to identify populations clearly
see where these populations may occur as
you can see here you know it looks
you've got two different populations all
the way to the left there in the
lymphocytes
and then gating through the different b
cells uh the cd38 hlavr ones you can get
very pure b cells which you can then
move to
doing v-style clones
and actually doing this research
the other thing is
to go back to that quickly is this is
into the 96 ball plate as i stated um
and the mechanism that the 96 well plate
is done on is is very much like an
asterios it's in this kind of a
arm
format instead of just a simple plate
shifting so the arm moves the plate
around very efficiently and again
as we showed
with one of the functions in that study
that we were doing and checking the
plate sorting is this is
very efficient also on a 96 well plate
you're sorting straight down so this is
less of a chance of uh static
electricity that is caused from the
plastic of the plates and the plastic of
the internal tubs
causing
the the particles that just kind of be
shot away from the actual well and hit
hitting maybe the top or the side and
never getting into the well per se
another application so we have an
individual we've been starting with for
many many years that is in you know a
neurology
program and they looked um
at alzheimer's disease and most recently
in most of their studies centering
around autism and you know autistic
spectral disorders
and so they started finding
uh
basically that they had
these lymphocyte cuffs they would call
them that were in these t cell
populations these are actually cytotoxic
toxic
t cells that would get into
uh
you know the brain which caused these
lymphocyte cuffs nearly astrocytes
and basically you'd end up
causing these type of reactions whether
you know some in alzheimer's type
fractions uh and definitely in the in
autism
and so they started looking at the
autism brains um so these were donated
either from
autistic patients or those alzheimer
patients and noticing these so they
wanted to get a better idea of the gene
library
so they started using crispr cast 9
modeling to in order to cut out
sequences and insert things to see okay
well if we can target the certain genes
and we know the gene library can we then
insert certain other things in order to
change
what is going on can we actually have
some sort of effect on autism or
alzheimer's
and so
that's basically what they were kind of
looking for
and again we're able to sit there and we
were doing different ones so they have
one model that uses an m cherry they
have one model that uses gnp and they
have another model that uses cfp and
we're able to do all of these
using the srt we actually move these
over from other instrumentation in order
to
have it more gentle we were having a lot
of
death in these swords
and so
we actually moved it over to see if that
100 micron nozzle tip on the 15 psi
would give better results and then the
viability
was actually
remarkably better um and
you know she started doing a lot more
uh library so we were able to speed
things up for her and get things moving
all right
more fun applications so this is vaccine
research these are starting with car t's
um this is a group that uh
here they have
uh
multiple publications are actually fda
approved uh vaccine using car t
and
a dc tumor fusion model
so basically what's happening is they're
able to give
the car t's a longer kind of time span
by getting in with a dc tumor fusion
vaccine
allowing for again we're talking about
those hidden uh tumor cells or cancer
cells
this allows
this car t platform to stay and actually
look for those so there's less
chance of you know
coming out of remission less chance of
having a different type of
um
oh look
hey we have from what i hear i have
video so
thank you very much joan appreciate that
uh so we can go back at some point and i
can show some fun stuff i think
so that's pretty awesome
but as we can see here this is a simple
type model where we have the
car t cells they're generated in normal
fashion we get the dendritic cells which
then fuse with the tumor cells it's a
peg mediated fusion
and each of these is working in in
synchrony to
wipe out the tumors
um and this was i believe in an aml so
and like i said this is an fda
approved vaccine through the abigain
david avignon group
here at uh beth israel
and this is basically the synergistic
vaccine approach as you can see we're
basically taking oh that picture looks
terrible sorry about that um these m
cherry labeled tumor cells
they are being fused with the dendritic
cells which are labeled cd86 and we're
taking
and we sort out the
dual population
we're then going to combine those with
what we sorted out of pure car tgfp
labels here
they're going to go undergo a t cell
clonal expansion and then the lovely
picture of this is a tumor cell and
these uh
and this actual fusion model this
vaccine approach is going to break down
and wipe out that tumor
so this is
again another extremely uh
good assay this is
great science clinically relevant you
know translational and i mean
being able to be part of this even in
the the sorting aspect
is just amazing to me
um
and not to mention they're a great group
to work with so
this is something that we're able to
help with again
keeping that cell viability very high is
extremely important car t cells tend to
be a little fragile so being able to
work with them and keep them alive
healthy makes this process go by faster
and in my head whether it's true or not
um this means that we're helping
patients
at a quicker rate and really doing our
part you know clinically
um something that's new that is a a
favorite of brandy again because the
individual that we've worked with yoshi
is such a wonderful individual and he
sat down and explained everything that
he's doing in his humanized mouse model
um while i've heard of before i don't
think i've ever
been part of
you know this and the sorting of it um
simply
you know you have the immunodeficient
mouse um you're
taking that and putting in human uh
uh hsc's stem cells
and you're waiting for this engraftment
validation so what happens after these
you know 12 weeks or so he brings the
cells to us and we're going to be
looking for them to be
um his stem cells in this mouse model
are labeled with a gfp
and then
along with the cd34 antibody this is
going to guarantee that we have
stem cells from the humanized mouse
so it's while it's a very
simple sort
per se you can see here it's basically
taking the cells making sure you have
singlets and then just looking at those
gfp
human stem cells
um and looking that they have anti-human
cd34 also on them and sorting that
population so that you know you have the
humanized mouse and then these humanized
mouse
mouse model can be used
for multiple multitude of experiments so
while simple it has such a high impact
um on what can be done in the science
that can be done with it
and again
just another one that it seemed like we
had some struggles with the the actual
uh viability and this just
took away those problems so
all right so we have extracellular
vesicle research i guess before we do
that maybe we'll try this whole camera
thing
um and we'll switch to this other camera
and hopefully if i can see myself
okay so
that actually is an srt
in real life
um
again if you're having any problems
seeing that because i think i'm doing
this right
let me know
but as you can see what we were talking
about is the door that that wonderfully
opens we'll try to bring this a little
bit closer
and you can see the tray here
i don't have any tubes in it at the
moment and
hopefully i can light this up
so you can see the lights here if you go
to the top that is where the plate would
sit and you can see the middle where a
slide would fit in
and you have the holders which allow for
15
and
5 ml
and you can see those little pieces
there they just kind of slide out so
that you can have four
five mls or you can do two 15 mls or two
fives and two 15s or
three fives and a 15. i think i got them
all
also here which i will
show
is an actual
nozzle tip
and you can see where it has all the
arrows and showed you and the little uh
holder so that's it in real life and
then it has this wonderful thing that i
said it comes with a package
uh and on that package is the very small
package insert which gives you the model
the instrument serial number the nozzle
serial number and the frequency and
amplitude that are have been optimized
for this particular nozzle within the
flow cell
so i mean they're kind of taking away
any inability to kind of think of what's
going on um i mean they made it pretty
easy here is the uh
sample injection area you can see the
tube holder
uh and that is there and the piece that
would actually come down on it and we'll
try to get into the software after and
run some of that
inside i told you the black box there
this is where you actually would insert
the nozzle tip
let me see if i put that camera down for
a minute
you can see where i would just
click that in
and to remove it you just push the side
pieces
so that one
and the one over here
and remove
and then your camera is here for your
streams so that's the whole camera
and then you can see your plates
lie with inside there
there are the plates
so those come out very easily also to
clean
and the whole chamber is pretty much uh
i call it kind of like that shower
bathtub
material it's very easily clean plastic
so you can use uh you know
ethanol or anything else that you want
to clean down with you can use bleach
inside the chamber though it gets a
little
bleach is a little strong of smell so 10
bleach more than enough
um and the waste catcher is there when
you're doing straight down sorting you
just move that waste catcher over and
surprise surprise in order to do that
it's just another wizard
so the
there's not much to think about there
again here's the top
so we'll do
that and you can see inside of here
where your actual
uh fluids come up through the sample
there's a pinch valve to pinch it when
not in operation not sorting there's
also it's hard to see maybe but there's
this little
thing here which is part of the bubble
detector so it sends it through this
little uh guide and if it detects a
bubble it'll stop the sort so that you
don't get a bunch of weird spraying and
materials that'll go into your actual
sample
and that's where it goes into the nozzle
and the basic plates where the frequency
and stuff occur
in the back like we said is your optic
so your little band pass filters and
whatnot and these little covers do come
off
i think i'm doing this right you can see
those inside there
and they tend to just look like this
thing open
so directing a camera and trying to open
something may not be
the easiest thing for me to do
so that is what the filter in real life
looks like put in perspective of my hand
it's got the little glass on the bottom
so that's actually your dichroic filter
where a certain light will go through
and others will bounce off as in that
cartoon
so in general that's basically entire
type system the fluidics are stationed
down um they just kind of pipe in
not very big it's a
it's set up for a
10
uh liter container you can readjust the
whole weight
of that the weight plate so that you can
do a larger
um
container and that's uh like i said very
under very low pressure the only other
things on that cart are filter
which obviously if that is a 200 micron
uh filter that's on the back it has its
waist like everything else
and it's actual cleaning fluid so that
when you're doing that shutdown that's
what's going to uh clean out the machine
during that five minutes the shutdown
period
um nothing else is very big it's a it's
a very small
computer that goes with it so i guess
the other
good thing is it it basically takes a
small
table i'm using an old aria table
actually this may be an lsr2 table
in order to put it on so not much space
taken up and like i said fluidics can go
on the floor so
which is another thing because i don't
know about anybody else but in my world
uh
space is
an extreme premium
so all right let's go back to the other
camera for the time being
hey there we go
and now we'll talk about like i said
what's there and dear to my heart i've
been doing this type research
for
god i don't know maybe eight to ten
years i don't remember exactly
it's where now
any grant that i'm on comes from
also papers and whatnot all come from
this and i've
gotten some great uh collaborators from
this uh
for those of you who may not have seen
it i believe earlier today there was a
talk by joshua welsh um i'm going to
mention some of the things that that
josh would have talked about his talk um
but i want to give credit where credit
is due as this is
a lot of this uh standardization that we
do before actually even trying
uh these materials on the citaflex s or
this srt
we run it through programs uh that jeff
is at the josh has established
got jeff franklin in my head for the
diffie-cells
um
so
obviously you know without josh having
that and us having access to it we would
not be able to even try this never mind
have some
successes so in our world we deal a lot
with these uh
uh red blood cell evs um here if you
want to copy that uh link that's gonna
get you your own copy of fcm pass to
play with
uh and
you know this is uh i will caveat that
by saying if you are at an academic
institution or doing academic work it is
free to you
if you are from a company uh such as you
will use beckman culture since we're
that's what we're talking about um
then you can make arrangements to uh to
get the software uh via a license
so and you can speak with josh about
those possibilities if you have
questions josh is extremely accessible
and will try to assist but there's a lot
of videos which will walk you through
exactly what needs to be done
so in our hands we took this uh i have
brandy who has become my ed expert i've
been able to kind of pass along some of
that knowledge and
i'd like to say that she
is learning everything from me but she's
been able to go way beyond
and do a lot of this work and uh and
then tell me how it works so
it's a lot of things you hear are my
words but are the knowledge that i've
been given from other individuals
so uh the biggest thing i'd like to
point out is this collection half ankle
and we spoke to josh about this we had a
a reasonable
expectation that it wasn't going to be
perfect um the cytoflex s is based on a
different flow cell than the srt
which you would never notice or have any
issues with if you're doing any kind of
sorting of cells you know lymphocytes
like you show the cartesian stem cells
ips anything else that we've played with
neurons
astrocytes it's it's not going to matter
but when you start talking about things
below
a micron it starts to matter a lot uh
and so it does have its effect on the
actual results and you know what your
limited detection is what we were happy
about is that we were able to get some
decent fits here and be able to do a
scattering cross-section
um
i'm not sure we had that complete
expectation because when we first
started working on this we did it as my
colleague would say very tenesca
so we kind of just threw everything
together and see what we got
and this is why i say get a lot of
knowledge from people that i collaborate
with because both josh and brandy said
that's not the way you do things
so i stopped and went back and said
sorry i get ahead of myself
because i get excited and i just want to
do stuff
so they made me go through the software
when i say made me they did it
and so they they showed me what our
expectations should be based on what the
you know what these angles are what this
software is putting out
so if we start to look at the actual
information we're going to see our
limited detection stocks creeping up
around 150
175 nanometer range and this is saying
that it's in a when we're looking at a
biological what on scatter is going to
be the lowest size we can see
without having a lot of issues or
you know
it's basically setting your expectations
of where it should be if it's a little
bit lower great
um
but here's
what what we should be looking at based
on all the information you're getting
from the lasers and how the software
looks at so how's the software doing
well if you saw josh he probably gave
you a much better presentation than i'm
going to
um but basically what we did is we take
miss beats and different sizes this is
basically what we have in this example
is from a 90 nanometer bu all the way up
to 400.
we go also to a 500 and add in a
thousand uh
silica we also tried some other silicas
but they don't play well simply because
the companies cannot give us a good
refractive index
when you talk to them you get a
it's kind of sort of maybe
this refractive index it's not very
helpful when you're trying to
standardize something and actually
produce
very
good data and let the software have the
best possible outcome and giving you
that standardization
also we did try an 80 nanometer bead
which is successful on the cytoflex s
not so much on the srt
we have seen it before but we had two
engineers basically sitting here playing
around with the optics while we did that
this is not we don't want to put that in
there this is the part that beckman
culture says no this is what you guys do
not us
so if you have two friendly engineers
and you can have them sit while you sort
always updating the actual output of the
lasers
then that's how you can get this done
um but you can see by putting these in
and actually running it through the
software
you can then tell the instrument okay
this is a hundred and the hundred shows
up on the hundred um these are no longer
arbitrary units these are actual
converted uh units so that they're put
into nanometers
so all these are corresponding to what
they do
all this software is doing for us is
telling us what the limit of detection
is giving us an idea of standardization
letting us know that hey you can try
now using the instrument for a certain
application
um
if this was a complete disaster we
couldn't move on any further
so what we first tried to do is we got
ourselves some virus-like particles um
which are
very closely related due to the fact
that these manufactured particles are
very round and circular which are
similar to an extracellular vesicle
which have a very much groundish shape
also
very much to our red blood cells which
are our spheres
yes they have that concave biconcave
shape like little donuts but they're
basically when they're new in a nice
round shape and when they bleb off
extracellular vesicles they are
absolutely round
so we wanted something that was
biologically relevant that was very
close so we get these virus-like
particles we've also tried um
these mouse leukemia virus particles
that you may have uh heard about
that we were able to get from our friend
uh veritang and
you know and try out and you get these
same type results so this is just us
showing that okay if we take these
particles that are it can be gfp labeled
or td tomato labeled or anything we
basically ask in the fluorescent protein
because he's using the gag proteins in
order to do this
then we can start to sort
so we're sitting there and we look what
i did is i use the fluorescence trigger
in this particular instance knowing that
my limited detection was only going to
be about 175 ish maybe even 200
that i wanted to get a little more out
of it so knowing that if i go to an
actual fluorescence trigger i can go
down the scale a little bit more
be able to see that i'm going to then
calibrate these according to some mesf
values you can buy mdsf beads and then
kind of
use those to get an idea of what your
limited detection according to your
fluorescence trigger will be
we found that being it that we were
bright enough because we were
approximately 3 000 copies of gfp on
these blps on the mouse lecamia virus
it's approximately 300 copies of a super
folded egfp
so you're getting even more so it's an
intensity thing not so much copy number
but you can relate those
so we set it up so that we were
basically looking at okay here's some
things that are behind and these are the
bright ones and we're going to sort them
out as you can see there we were able to
do that with a high efficiency
so we were very happy with what we were
doing but we kind of knew these were
manufactured they're very
if
if it was going to be successful this is
what was going to work so
this is what we did
after that we decided okay let's go into
something a little more robust so we
started playing around with these
molecular beaches and the reason we did
the molecular beacons is because this is
a project that we've been working on
we've had some
wonderful papers that have been
published in regards to looking at a
molecular beacon molecular beacon is a
hairpin loop structure which has a
quencher which is known as a black hole
quencher or dark quencher
and a fluorescence uh tag
when the the actual loop sequence is the
hairpin is there and tightened up
um the quencher is close enough in
proximity to the fluorescence marker and
it's called a quencher you don't see
fluorescence
when the
complementary sequence that you put in
such as a micro rna 451a which is a
a
red blood cell marker micro rna then it
will open up that sequence
and your fluorescence will actually show
up and occur
so we did this by taking those we we
labeled
our
micro rna 451s with with the particular
complementary molecular beacon these
molecular beacons were mixed with the
red blood cells they were able to insert
into the red blood cell by a cell
penetrating peptides instead of using
like an electropluration or maybe
sonication or something that would give
the same effect
red blood cells are
a little bit easier also because if you
know if you squeeze them or anything
like that they do open up and then seal
themselves back off so their membranes
are very good for these this type
research
we then activated these using like an
iomycin uh and you know some sort of
ionophore and in this case it was
ionomycin
and it starts to generate out
extracellular vesicles exosomes
in this particular case and you can see
here
what we did on this fluorescence is we
tried i tried to split this in a 50 50.
so we took 50 of what should be
considered
molecular beacon negative and we took 50
of what should be molecular beacon
positive
now i put question marks here because
the biggest thing we were discussing
with our collaborators and we sat down
and this is dr garan and myself and
brandi and said hey
how do we know
that these are
absolutely negative that they don't have
a molecular beacon or they just so
happen that they're below the limit of
detection and they're inserting
themselves in the noise
now we're not geniuses it was simply
because if we're running the machine and
looking at its background
uh of just you know some fluids of pbs
we notice oh boy
we get a certain events per second let's
call it a thousand events per second
and then when we added in our molecular
beacons
it would go to say five thousand six
thousand events per second
well that's not just the positive
fraction that didn't make sense if you
look at what's going on we were seeing
an increase in what events per second in
just that noise region also so you say
well
it doesn't it's not a leap of faith here
per se to say that there may be
something in there so we decided to sort
them both out
and once we sorted them out we got those
tubes we concentrated them so anybody
who's done ev stuff you're going to say
well that's a lot of fluid well we
concentrated them after that so we have
here this whole sequence and these are
positives right and what is supposed to
be negatives we take them we put them
into amicon filter tubes centrifuge uh
very very briefly to concentrate the
sample and then look at them under the
microscope this is using um an olympus
microscope with a dockfield condenser
which you can also look at using that
same thing to look at fluorescence and
as you can see here we've got a lot more
within the positive region and you can
see those little guys uh when you really
focus in on a region
and then doing the same thing with the
negatives when you you look there's a
lot less
but they're there
and so you end up looking at them and
yes you have
evs that are molecular beacon positives
sitting there and they happen to just be
that they're either not as bright
or in our particular instance we found
that they may be a part of a certain
cell population
and that's why they're below the limit
of detection
but they do exist
we're at the part we have some
acknowledgements
so we'd like to acknowledge
people here at bi dmc at the nih
especially uh as i said josh welsh for
his uh wonderful insight and just uh
having the
the insight to make the software which
made our lives a lot easier we had the
uh the engineers uh and team from
beckman culture that we talked about
really tightening up these instruments
and making them uh you know perform
at at maximum efficiency
and then just to give the uh
kudos to those who gave us data the
fujisaki lab with muller
uh rhys k the sage labs cecilia
and the anderson lab monica nadler we
had our individuals from the abigain lab
jessica and julia and from uh
yoshihiro yoshi
and then we go on to
thank you for your time let's see if
there's questions and i may have
really gone over i can't remember
precisely
so thank you for your attention sorry
for the technical difficulties to begin
with i hope i was able to show the
instrument so that it was a little bit
more
clear
okay
so joan or scott are you there
um hi john i'm here just give me a
moment let me get scott here
yeah no problem joan i i thank you very
much because i know
um
difficulties on your end also so
i appreciate you
jumping in
no problem at all
okay nothing live from london
and i don't see anything in me in the
question box
which means either i was extremely
efficient or most people think that guy
doesn't know what he's talking about
and i'm okay either way
well i guess we have no more questions
from the audience if there is anything
could we direct them to your email
address yeah please send them to my
email address i'll try to answer them uh
as quickly as possible um
and again i thank everybody for their
attention and time
uh apologize for anything that may have
not come off clearly and hopefully
things that may need some uh some
explanation reach out to me and uh i
don't even mind if we have to do it like
this and assume so it can be clear for
you
thank you so much sean for your time ben
ah there we go i do have a question
quickly then
um so the average size on those
particular ones so the viral uh
particles tend to be somewhere between
90 and 110
um where the monster premier virus i
think is strictly at 120
and then when the evs that we had sorted
um those
have two different populations one that
sits kind of in a
in 80 nanometer range and another that's
somewhere around 125 to 150.
yes and uh not if you look up josh there
is a a ton of good information on his
particular page through the uh nih and
uh national cancer institute um and if
you find me
i have some stuff on our webpage at beth
israel and also i don't mind sending you
any information you may need
if you're looking to do ev sorting on
any instrument
that's great then john thank you very
much for your time
and
i'm so sorry about these technical
issues earlier and i hope you're able to
share all that you wanted to
i i i think i did i you know
we adapt right
so we have one question that just came
in would you like to take one last one
ah so to sort ev's markers there are
different types us particularly so um we
ended up with a fluorescent protein
which um was on the virus uh particles
or the leukemia virus particles
those are basically gfp based
the
red blood cell evs we have looked at
them via
a cell mask
green or red and this is particularly
the molecular beacons which have a
fluorescence tag that is fam 488
that it comes but you can get anything
you want on them for you know if you
want a q-dot you can do that any
antibody that you think of the problem
with markers is it's very difficult to
find universal markers some use lipid
dyes you know there's diet and apps
there's a dii dio dil
those type things
we've used malamide
for these type studies
um and then also that i know people know
of the tetraspanins our issue with
tester spannings is uh well red blood
cells do not contain tetraspanins
um
so that's an issue for us but
and we have also found that trying to
use a glycophorin a235a
is not necessarily
what we thought so red blood cells have
tons of it but when they bleb off not
all of their evs contain it
and this was confirmed doing uh
you know
cryo-em with nano bill of particles
[Music]
you